Elizabeth Branham joins me now live from
New Delhi Liz
so Narendra Modi has spoken about the
deaths of these soldiers what's he had
to say Prime Minister Narendra Modi said
that the deaths of the 20 soldiers will
not be in vain he also said that the
sovereignty of India is the most
important thing and that India wants
peace but that it's capable of what he
called a befitting reply if instigated
he's also called for a meeting of all
the major political parties on Friday to
discuss this situation he's held
meetings with defense Chiefs already and
also with his own cabinet ministers and
we've had high-level military talks
taking place between India and China in
the galois alley where the clashes
happened on Monday we've heard from
China's foreign ministry which has said
that it's open to communication but it's
comments aren't going to be
well-received in India because it's also
said that the sovereignty of the Dewan
Valley belongs to India well that is
going to be come as a surprise to many
in India defense experts say that China
is expanding its territorial claims and
the Ministry of External Affairs had
said that China was trying to
unilaterally change the status quo
during de-escalation efforts in the
region of eastern Ladakh we know that
both sides had increase their military
presence in the region following
skirmishes in May that Indian defense
experts were accusing China of
encroaching into Indian territory and
they had been asking the government what
it was doing about it
well the government had been holding
talks with China with both sides saying
that they have the diplomatic channels
in place to resolve any border disputes
through dialogue and yet we have reports
these 20 deaths in fact confirmed at a
time when the Indian government was
assuring the public that it had the
situation under control but now there
are a lot of questions about whether in
fact it does and a lot of pressure
hall's for india to act against china
okay listen if this is possible pressure
facing the government mike india became
to de-escalate though given this
imbalance in military power or perhaps
other reasons as well
so if you look at what's in that and
Ramadi had to say that the death of the
20 soldiers is not going to be in vain
and also that you know they're capable
of a big fitting response if they're
provoked well that's that's it doesn't
seem like he wants to deescalate from
that and again he is under a lot of
pressure there are protests out on the
streets they are small there are still
restrictions on the number of people who
can gather but there have been protests
and lots of cities around the country
including outside the Chinese embassy by
Army veterans calling for action against
China
there's the hashtag boycott China and
boycott Chinese products is trending on
Twitter India has a very nationalist
media and they're all calling for action
against China and again India is not
going to respond well to the Chinese
Foreign Ministry statement either
because again they were calling for
communication but they're really blaming
India for everything that happened and
as I mentioned defense experts here say
that claiming the sovereignty of the
galois on Valley the entire sovereignty
of that well that's new and that that's
not part of China's territory thanks for
that
Elizabeth pranam there live from New
Delhi Katrina Hugh has more now from the
Chinese capital Beijing China says it's
in close communication with India by
both diplomatic and military channels
foreign ministry spokesperson jolly Jen
spoke to the media today on Wednesday
and said that both sides were intent on
resolving this dispute through peaceful
dialogue and that China did not want to
see any further clashes at the same time
jolly Jen laid the blame for the deadly
brawl on Monday solely at the feet of
India according to Beijing the two
slides actually reached a consensus on
the border dispute on June 6th but
Indian troops violated this consensus
and he said they provoked and attacked
Chinese personnel he also went on to
urge the Indian military to discipline
its troops he won't want to say further
that the location where this altercation
took place
Goldwyn Valley he said that this was and
has always been Chinese territory
something that's heavily disputed by
India and he said that clearly it was
clear that who was on the right and the
wrong side of this class that resulted
in the deaths of those soldiers on
Monday now according to Indian media
there were Chinese casualties as well
but the Chinese government is yet to
release any numbers and there is some
speculation that they may never release
these numbers a state media here are
saying that this is in fact a sign of
goodwill from Beijing an example of
Beijing wanting to pursue peace with
India and not wanting to spark any
confrontational sentiment that may lead
to all-out conflict